avec un sujet qui je le sais est assez
polémique puisque suite à la libération
d'otages de touristes français qui a
coûté la vie à deux militaires au
burkina faso il ya quelques jours la
polémique sont les voyages à risque et
relancer le 19/20 nationale a enquêté
sur ce phénomène qui attire tout de même
une poignée de français
le vin des éléphants une expérience hors
du commun dans une zone pourtant
déconseillé par les autorités française
patricia mecs on a l'habitude de ce type
de voyage il y a cinq mois elle était
d'ailleurs dans le parc de la pendjari à
l'époque dit-elle zone en vigilance
renforcée elle a probablement emprunté
les mêmes routes que celles des ex
otages capturés le 1er mai dernier
partir dans des pays qui ont les
touristes ne vont pas trop pour moi
c'est une réelle satisfaction
mais avant de s'aventurer dans ces zones
cette femme prend des précautions
la première s'enregistrer sur le site du
quai d'orsay patricia bekx on évite tout
de même les territoires rouge fortement
déconseillé le quai d'orsay ne peut pas
interdire aux voyageurs de s'y rendre en
europe seuls quelques agences de voyage
proposent des circuits dans des zones
dangereuses et on ne peut qu'avoir une
pensée évidemment pour les deux
militaires qui ont été tués lors de la
libération des otages cédric de pierre
pons et alain berton de celle on a une
pensée évidemment pour eux et pour leurs
familles qu'est ce que l'on pense de ce
fait ce début de polémique
on va aller mais on va élargir on va
aller plus loin effectivement il ya
quelques touristes qui disent que il
faut aller là où on a envie d'aller peu
importe les zones oranges jaunes or aux
roses ou autre notamment il ya des zones
qu'on dont on n'imagine pas qu'elles
sont à risque et quand on va sur le site
du quai d'orsay
on se dit bah tiens finalement les
philippines qui a priori on n'a pas le
sentiment que eh ben c'est quand même un
endroit dangereux
qu'est ce que vous en pensez caroline
alors il ya beaucoup de choses à dire je
trouve sur ce sujet moi je fais partie
vraiment de la catégorie touristes qui
n'a pas du tout envie d'aller là où les
autres vous donc c'est vrai que je vais
toujours aller vers quelque chose de un
peu exotique peut être parfois un petit
peu à la limite de la dangerosité
bordeaux et voilà je n'ai pas envie
concept du terrain pardon je sais que
vous trouvez vous vos chez de la tête ah
ouais vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas du
tout d'accord avec moi mais très bien
mais parlons-en
auger pas eu pour le concept du terrain
à la violence au terrorisme etc
c'est pas eux qui vont m'empêcher de
passer des vacances est par ailleurs sur
cette histoire précisément il faut quand
même savoir et sans former un tout petit
peu et ne pas répéter bêtement
ce qu on a vaguement entendu c'est quand
même le parc en question était dans la
zone jaune au moment où les touristes se
sont exercés grand danger mais ça veut
pas dire non plus qu'il était dans la
joue dans la zone rouge
des carla orange et c'est un parc qui
est divisé en plusieurs zones jaune
orange rouge
il n'était pas dans la zone rouge donc
effectivement ils ont peut-être chercher
un tout petit peu d'exotisme d'aller
dans des zones peu en dehors des
sentiers battus ils ont pris un risque
c'est vrai c'était mais non seulement
ils prennent un risque mais il met en
marché qui viendrait événements les
sauver si par malheur elle aura dès qu'
ils ont pensé en amont je pense qu'il y
avait quelque chose de très égoïste dans
l'or dans leurs risques carole eliard
exemple que pour vos prochaines vacances
même si on vous met en garde même si
vous allez sur le site du ministère de
deux des affaires étrangères et que vous
voyez une zone un petit peu à risque
qu'elle soit the jaune orange rouge vous
dirai c'est quand même là que j'ai envie
d'aller gérer jamais dans une zone rouge
mais c'est vrai qu'une zone jaune par
exemple ça me fait pas peur d'y aller là
où savoir aussi que ce que dit le quai
d'orsay n'est pas toujours compatible
avec ce que va dire le pays en question
le ministre le ministère des affaires
étrangères dont la la la la limite elle
est assez subtil aussi par accor ok
ludivine je sens que vous êtes exaspéré
mais je suis totalement exaspérés par
mawâzine parce que malheureusement ce
sont des personnes aussi inconsciente et
égoïste quels mots qui mène à des drames
comme comme la wiimote bien sûr que oui
je suis désolé il ya un moment donné où
quand on me parle d'exotisme excuse-moi
exotisme en quoi gaza c'est plus
exotiques bora bora
je ne comparerai pas en l'occurrence non
ce sont des personnes qui sont avides de
sensations fortes qui aime flirter avec
le danger et qui met évidemment ou à la
plage les autres en péril le quai
d'orsay donne des directives pourquoi ne
pas les suivre
il ya quoi est ce que ça veut dire que
par exemple vous voudriez qu'on
interdise à mais le terrain je suis pour
le durcissement des règles en allemand
avec a complètement d'accord
vous vous seriez vous pour le
durcissement des règles pour interdire
l'accès à taloqan parce qu'on dit c'est
rouge mais vous pouvez y aller
vous empêche de prendre un billet est de
faire comme ludivine et utilisent et
rhétorique que je trouve très dangereuse
de dire que vous mettez en danger la vie
des autres bases dans ça c'est la même
rhétorique qui fait que quand une femme
en boîte de nuit à 3 heures du matin non
si on lui dit rien si tu t'es fait
violer oui bah c'est à 3 heures du matin
ou démence exact on aime rêver c'est à
dire est que un enfant qui joue avec des
allumettes qui mettrait le feu bon
attendez c'est l'enfant qui est
responsable et non pas quelqu'un qui
aura l'accident de la route qui n'aurait
pas mis sa ceinture de sécurité
bah pourquoi le sauver il n'a pas mis sa
ceinture à la sanaga c'est une démarche
volontaire on sait qu'on va dans un
endroit qui équipe alors en fonction du
degré un peu beaucoup très dangereux
qu'on prend des risques en france comme
le dit caroline il n'était pas dans la
zone rouge zone noire une horrible ils
flirtent pas avec celles ci on regarde
ça effectivement on va plus nulle part
dans le monde à maman je voulais pas
emballé au liban et j'étais sur le site
en me disant vous voulez vous on rêvait
d'aller au liban et on nous dit on on
n'en fait jamais y aller attention c'est
dangereux pendant plus de deux ans j'ai
regardé et à aucun moment fallait y
aller on a plein d'amis qui vont qui
bombent a finalement tout va bien donc
où se trouve la limite et finalement
nous qui avons subi des attentats
pourquoi le finalement notre pays on
nous dit toujours qu'on en alerte
maximum que la france est sous danger
imminent
ça reste à mon sens tout aussi grave et
ce qui est dramatique c'est la fête nous
du gouvernement qui a dit que ces
touristes étaient irresponsables et que
ces touristes etc news parce que là en
l'occurence n'était pas une zone rouge
dans ces cas là on a averti les gens
attention aux landes the oranges et
badens et carrément vers la personne on
vous laissera mourir sur place il se
passe quelque chose ça vous l'assumez
c'est un double discours que je trouve
moi insupportable ludivine visiblement
vous n'êtes absolument pas d'accord avec
des mille îles est insupportable parce
que et je ne connaissais pas comme ça
mon voisin c'est d'une démagogie
moi j'estime qu'effectivement on a le
droit de partir en a le droit de vouloir
aller dans des zones et un peu moins
fréquenté que d'autres bombes à la
maison les dames et non de un peu moins
fréquenté que dans d'autres adossés les
fonds mais qu'ils soient tolérées et
qu'ils soient prônée par le quai d'orsay
comme une zone où effectivement on peut
aller tu te dis pas de partir forcément
nécessairement au soleil tout le temps
dans la caraïbe ou autre mais pourquoi
aller se mettre en danger
mettre d'autres personnes en danger
après les demandes de rançons et tout
c'est l'argent public qui est utilisé
pour sauver des personnes sont et
alimentaires m'a posé la cause juste a
rejoint juste te dire ludivine tu es
quand même une attitude très très
française d'être dans ta bulle haute aux
centristes
parce que les béninois et j'en connais
pas mal ils nous le disent sont
scandalisés par cette polémique
chez eux
ce n'est pas plus dangereux qu'en france
il nous renvoie au bataclan en effet et
à charlie hebdo et nous disent chez nous
ça arrive ça arrive aussi chez vous
aimez ça normal le sait il va pas dire
qu'il est d'organiser une zone
dangereuse et compliqué bon les
touristes dans les zones à risques on
vous a posé la question à nos
téléspectateurs à c'est leur choix ou
bien c'est inconscient si les divines
vous remportez là-dessus évident le
débat puisque pour 73 % de nos
téléspectateurs
c'est inconscient